what up guys welcome to the just hurry
things YouTube channel and welcome to my
whiteboard series before I start don't
forget to subscribe to the channel and
bring that notification Bell that way
you're going to be notified of my daily
videos and while you're at it guys get
yourself a women shouldn't vote t-shirt
today all of the world's problems are
really caused by women voting so today
we are going to be talking about why it
is irresponsible to tell young men to
get married today now I know what you're
thinking Pearl but you grew up with nine
siblings in a two-parent home
why would you ever say such an evil
thing well before you get mad let me
just explain back in the day
we had a woman and we had a man these
two guys and the woman typically would
get out of the marriage she would get
protection from the man if someone broke
into your house your guy would come and
defend your honor and die doing it she
would also get a guy to provide now what
does this mean essentially he would take
care of the bills on top of that he
might fix stuff around the house that's
like a traditional guy right your faucet
breaks he'll help you he takes care of
the bills and protects you now in
exchange he got kids 150 years ago it
was maybe seven plus kids you know
pretty good right now on top of that he
would get a virgin
the guys are like where can I find one
of those in 2023. he would get then the
average wife was 120 pounds so she was
thin she was a virgin she'd give you
seven kids she could cook and clean so
essentially manage a household on top of
that she served her husband and she
worked on the farm so this often came
with sometimes they would learn an
instrument for when guests came over
they would help milk the cows if you
guys want to look into what life was
like 150 years ago Google a day in the
life of the Amish and ask yourself could
you do what those women do now so this
was the exchange now fast forward it's
2023. the average man does protect his
family the average man is expected to
protect the family unit and we have a
bunch of Institutions and systems that
are run by men that protect women so me
if I am in danger I can call the police
if someone attacks me on the street
typically it's more likely that I'll
other men will defend women than another
man on top of that the military which
protects the country is run by men and
all of the hard jobs are done by men so
this means working on an oil rig working
in the factories majority men on top of
that the average man does make more than
the average woman and even when you look
at more close to 50 50 relationships the
man still does the majority of the bills
typically men you know while a man
probably can't build a house nowadays he
typically has more traditional skills
than the average woman now to be fair
we're all kind of we all know less so
not just the women but okay so now let's
look at what the average woman provides
the average woman will maybe give you
two kids at most so this has gone way
down the average woman has slept with
five to eight Partners one out of Threes
had an abortion one out of three has an
STD and ninety percent have been on
birth control and so at some point in
their lifetime no longer a Verge okay
the average woman is 170 pounds that is
50 pounds more and they don't even have
seven children gas and the average woman
is not known for cooking and cleaning
there are studies that show that takeout
is going up and on top of that more
microwave meals are more popular
nowadays than cooking so that is gone
okay so you guys get the idea women are
worse than ever before where men have to
do practically what they've always done
all right so let's let's go okay now
let's talk about marriage right now what
we have is a marriage system this is
backed up by the state now you can have
your opinions about whether or not
marriage should be backed up by the
state but right now this is a legally
enforced system and this system includes
man and woman get married
woohoo they're in love what a day then
step two is man and woman
have kids typically about two so let's
do two baby children right there so they
have kids fall in love they have their
kids and now the woman for whatever
reason just isn't feeling it anymore she
was feeling it yesterday she was feeling
him the day before but now she's not
feeling it so women initiate divorce 70
to 80 percent of the time and typically
when we look at the reasons for divorce
the men's reasons for divorce are a bit
more serious like a drug problem or
women is just irreconcilable differences
and they weren't happy so okay we got
the woman Lee we're gonna do break up oh
no the saddest the problem is now the
woman
gets to use these kids to steal money
from the man for a lifetime for a
lifetime so for about 18 years the woman
says give me money or you don't see your
kids now what we have is other men so
the police the government putting a gun
to this guy's head and saying give her
money otherwise you go to jail now how
many people are in this marriage system
we have divorce lawyers Family Court
which is judges the lawyers again the
women's shelters on top of that
politicians are given a cut the gut the
taxes take cut etc
etc etc so this system only works if men
sign up to get married and essentially
when we break down marriage right we
have the men getting married and then so
this is the marriage then we have the
divorce lawyers the women's shelters the
politicians questions
judges that all make money off of women
taking men's kids so they all get a cut
out of this so women are literally paid
to steal men's kids they are paid to
accuse men of rape and abuse and there
are government incentives for all of
these things now we could go back and
forth about what percent of men this
happens to but it would be considered
negligent to issue a product that
destroyed someone's life five percent of
the time I would argue that it's much
higher than that being that every guy
that I know seems to know someone that's
been falsely accused or can't see his
kids but the media doesn't really care
about men's issues so you'll never hear
about it so a lot of times men go
through this process right and you have
to think about what these guys go
through so they lose all their money
they lose their kids and a lot of times
they're accused of abuse and everybody
thinks they're an abuser so they come
out of this very distraught the average
age of divorce for a man is 46. so he's
often spent 20 years building up his
life just for this chick right here to
ruin it now a lot of times in this
process men do commit suicide this is a
very taboo very sad topic but men go
through this and they go crazy and they
kill themselves if you talk to any men's
rights Advocate any person that has
worked with men trying to get them
access to their children a lot of men do
kill themselves in the process so again
I go back to a car analogy if we had a
car that killed five percent of the
people in it we would recall that car
but yet we still tell men that they are
not real men if they don't get married
we say marriage makes you a better
person therefore insinuating that you
were a bad person if you don't choose
this system that pays women to divorce
you take your kids and call you an
abuser so now what's the solution a lot
of people say pearl you're just a Doomer
why would you tell men to knock get
married you evil woman ah blah blah blah
what what are the solutions here I grew
up with nine siblings Pearl likes
families all right I think families are
good but how do we get to a point where
these people are together again well we
have to weigh the risks and the rewards
now regardless of what I say men just
naturally look at a situation and Ray
the risks and the rewards so before the
reward used to be seven children
obedient wife a thin wife and she could
not legally leave you she was stuck and
he also got Purity I forgot Purity so
that used to be the reward but now he
gets a born-again virgin that's fat I
mean he could at least get a thin white
and generally the women stay thin for a
lifetime now they do not and men look at
the odds and they say oh they say
oh no my grandpa got screwed over by my
grandma or they'll say oh my friend was
falsely accused my friend this happened
to my friend my friend can't see his
kids and they'll say okay all of these
risks right so the risks would be lose
kids wife leaves stuff gone World thanks
I'm an abuser and the reward would be I
get a fat that's maybe slept with
I don't know three other men four other
men tent one Whatever guys whatever
number you're gonna put not a virgin so
fat no Trad skills controlling
nowadays social media is her God so
narcissist a lot yeah so now what do
they get in return the men so we say hey
men marry us please and he says okay can
you be thin we're like no can you be a
virgin we're like no he's like okay can
you at least at least just like cook
every day could I get that we're like ah
well there's an air fryer cook for
yourself I don't cook okay well could I
could you just listen to me could you
all obey me and we say Well only when
you're following the Lord so the child
say or they'll say they'll say no I
don't I don't listen to my husband he
can't control me then he's like could
you at least listen to my problems we're
like no we just love to talk about
ourselves and so the guys kind of look
at this Marketplace and they say okay
this would be the my reward for being
awesome and these are my risks so
there's a couple Solutions there's
really only two ways moving forward you
can a shame men and tell them that
they're not real men if they don't sign
up for this you can tell men to roll the
dice and just pick a good pick a good
woman that went to church and pray to
God she doesn't do this to you even
though I have spoken to many men that
dated religious women do you know any
religious women that screwed over their
guy yeah do you do you see okay this is
just a random room all right so the only
solution going forward is to lower the
risks so we changed the laws this means
um I would argue that men should
automatically get custody of children
however we could make the case that it's
split 50 50. the men are actually
willing to compromise unlike women so I
I bet you you think that's reasonable at
least 50 50. get rid of banned child
support ban alimony if you can't afford
your kids and give them to him and
really start to shame these women that
do this get rid of no fault divorce get
rid of child support alimony and maybe
the man can divorce you if you get fat
there's nothing worse to a man than a
fat wife and you're entitled to none of
his stuff none you wanted to be a single
independent woman go get a job like the
rest of them now on the other hand
another way another thing we can do is
increase the reward now the men don't
really trust us anymore and can you
blame them with Amber Heard and all of
these famous Liars I mean I wouldn't
trust us either one thing we can do is
at least not get fat ladies we can at
least stay in shape for a lifetime now
the other thing is we can encourage the
younger women to remain virgins until
their wedding day I mean this would be
good all right we could start to learn
more traditional skills or at least
listen to our boyfriend slash husband
and Obey male Authority oh I know oh you
guys aren't gonna like this one and in
my opinion until you start lowering the
risk for men all you are doing is
creating what I call the simping system
this is simp
now this is the marriage divorce and
this is going to be taking men's money
and giving it to women and then you
start over so because you know some guys
sign up for this more than once how
crazy is that so this is marriage
divorce take the men's money and give it
to the women now we have more than one
simping system it's not just marriage
let's do taxes where you take the men's
money and you issue handouts and then
give it to the women now this is not the
only Sim system also
corporations give Women fake useless
jobs this is when corporations give
Women fake jobs like human resources and
really any job that you hear the title
and you're like what the hell does that
mean like the head of diversity and
inclusion so you do nothing is what I
hear you do nothing and they basically
give women these fake jobs which is
funded for with the men's money they
make and given to the women and this is
just an entire system of simping so the
corporations are simping with these fake
jobs that make women feel so important
now it doesn't just stop there
the school system gives women these fake
great and fake accomplishments to think
they're so amazing and special and they
take the men's money and it funds the
school system and gives it to what guys
what is it women now how do you have
change in one of these systems why would
the lawyers judges politicians and
everybody change anything if men keep
signing up for a system where women are
paid to destroy them I have your answer
folks never this should be the number
one issue that all politicians are
talking about I want to know from Trump
to Santa's Biden everybody running for
president this election what is your
plan to stop this simp system now and
I'll tell you what I tend to see this is
just the Tendencies so typically the
average age of first divorce for a man
is 46. so what I see is men under the
age of 46 tell men around the age of 21
or 22 just to get married young buckle
up boys sign up for this mess and I
would argue you that is very naive and
if a man chooses to get married he
should be very trepidatious and provide
every possible caution before signing up
because this system does profit off of
making your life a living hell don't
shoot the messenger guys let me know
what you think in the comments and let
me know what policies you would like to
see past to stop this simp system
epidemic foreign
[Music]